thanks for me so I'm going to talk about
answering frequently asked questions in
bunch of these areas this is mostly
based on John [ __ ] with my colleague
hung at Buffalo and it's two in my mood
and Chris at Stanford and some of the
stuff that I'm going to talk about also
is joint with dang knowing who's that
logic blocks and Ellie Porthos it bore a
lot so in my house the most frequently
asked questions are what and why by my
son but we're going to talk about more
precisely mathematically defined
problems I'm going to talk about a baby
version of the general fa cues and
that's going to be the focus of my talk
alright so here's the definition of the
baby faq question you're given n
variables so let's call them x0 to xn
minus 1 so here's an example with three
variables and you haven't hyper graph on
these variables and then you have hyper
edges so here's a simple triangle graph
and i'll call the edges are s and T for
each edge e in this hyper graph I have a
function what I'll call fact I just
following the nomenclature in
probabilistic graphical models that maps
some stuff to some range i'll also have
a number F which is between 0 and n
which corresponds to a number of what I
call free variables so this is the input
what do you want to compute is
essentially the sum of product ok so you
sum up over all bound variables
variables that are not free and for
every edge in the hypergraph you compute
the corresponding factor value and
multiply out of these value over all
factors and sum it up the addition and
multiplication operator over this range
script d will form a semi ring I want to
mention that this baby fe cube is
already explicitly defined much before
our work in fact the earliest explicit
work that we know is due to RG and
michael is very nice kind of a semi
survey paper from 2000 all right oh so
we call it faq because it also
corresponds to functional aggregate
so you're a bunch of functions you want
to add we get together right in case you
like me before I started this work and
you don't remember the definition of
some earrings because you saw it may be
in your discrete math class and forgot
so here's a quick kind of reminder not
these kinds of summer rings so for
example the boolean semi ring which the
values are bit 0 and 1 and logical or
and that essentially want to do addition
and multiplication but you don't have
subtraction and division that's
essentially it you can also replace or
by addition and by multiplication and
you can replace 01 by set the set of
complex numbers so you get your usual in
fact this case it will be a feel so
slightly more formally the addition
forms accommodative monitor the addition
is commutative and it's closed under the
values in this set D and there's a
special element 0 which is the additive
identity and similarly have a
commutative Mon art for the
multiplication where one is the identity
element I've been putting a star across
some errands because that if i remember
correctly the traditional definition
doesn't need the multiplication to be
committed but we will in our case ok and
then multiplication distributes over
addition and 0 and highlights every
other element when you multiply on ok to
question what is sorry are the functions
can you go back one slide are the
boolean functions not necessarily so
they are on this range d 0 so we are
going to consider the cases with a
ranger complex numbers though the
bullying case is going to be very
important case as you make mac right so
these functions can take values in t so
it turns out that these baby faq is are
very expressive and effective work of
jean-michel is i think of an american
Lisicki Stan or more problems that you
can express that special instances of
this some product so if you think about
it for a bit you can you can express
constraint satisfaction or boolean can
say satisfaction problems over the
boolean semi rings you can talk about
publicity graphical models in particular
exact inference if you know what it
means but the values are not
numbers anyway the usual addition and
multiplication you can talk about logic
to I'm not sure if you can read it the
sciences honk if and only if you love
formal logic and there's also bunch of
problems in databases including the
joints problem that you can express as a
special case of this now it's a bunch of
matrix operation so make in particular
matrix vector multiplication so in this
talk I'm going to focus mostly on the
joints problem if that names case you
don't worry I'm going to give a version
that you would be very familiar with and
I'm going to talk about the matrix
vector operation so my plan and the rest
of the talk is to first show you why
these two are special cases of this baby
faq and then give you some algorithmic
solutions to this or any because these
are functional aggregate queries that
are frequently asked in just because i
had a three month old kid so I could
show the picture knowledge babies
because i'm the general version is more
general than the version that i showed
you so so our main results is we
essentially have one single algorithm
that will solve the general non baby faq
version which i am not yet defined
basically it gives you one algorithm to
rule all these pesky pesky semi rings at
once it turns out that these algorithms
then specialized to these special
problems in some problems in
probabilistic graphical models and logic
actually give you algorithms that run
way faster than that were previously
known and for other problems like joins
and matrix vector multiplication they
recover best-known results and again I'm
going to focus mostly on these two guys
here the technically challenging part is
the analysis of the algorithms in fact
our algorithm are not necessarily new
they are just simple twists on things
that were already known but I won't have
time to talk about analysis all right so
to Tony's question why baby so this is
the baby version we talked about here is
the grown-up version what do you learn
to go on to send the baby version the
summation operator
overall the bound variables are the same
whereas in the general version you the
i-x I will have its own can have its own
operator + okay in particular we allow
this operator to be multiplication or if
it's not the multiplication operator
then this plus I and multiplication
forms a simmering but they are all
simmering on the same set of values d
that's kind of any questions on the
definition location is the same for all
the multiplication is also the same for
audio yeah the only their dish well yeah
the only the addition to change alright
so the reason why this grown-up version
is interesting so it can handle things
like quantified conjunctive formulas so
you can exist they're all and then you
can also do countin stuff like that
sergeant I won't going to the details i
said i'm going to focus more on the baby
version alright so i'm going to next
talk about joints and this matrix
operation will show you why they're
special cases contain especially cases
of this baby faq problems so i'm not
going to formally define the john
problem i'm going to give you a
definition which should be probably more
natural to this audience but morally is
the joints problem so you're given a big
hyper graph G so let's say G is the
graph of the internet and you have a
small hyper graph H so say this is the
triangle graph you had earlier and the
joint problem essentially they want to
output all copies of etching G now this
technicality whether it's induce are not
induce let's just not worry about that
so here is a simple way to encode this
problem in this baby faq version so
defined so this sy are corresponds to
this edge are for FX and voice 1 of x
and y is an edge and just to make sure
they're not duplicates you just say x is
strictly less than what if we're
thinking of x and y is belonging to
these set of vertices and let's say we
number them from say 12 members so it's
you blow up the vertices into a cloud
with values and also just whip you just
map them one-to-one say from numbers
from 1 to n certain picture people you
used to have an assignment to each
vertex no no this is just a variable
just a variable yeah and similarly you
define it for science and site is so if
you just look at it for Matt what this
says is exist phi of x 0 x 1 and x 2 is
one if and only if x 0 x 1 is in our x 1
x 2 is an S and x0 x2 is in t so phi of
x 0 x 1 x 2 is one if an onlay if it
forms a triangle in the graph let's send
its encoding the set of triangles okay
there is a question of how you encode
the functions and I will come back to
that in a bit and that turns out to be a
bit crucial all right so let me talk
about matrix vector multiplication so
what do you get for the sound and sense
but you have to be now save something
but the sound of parrots all rights a
good one so here I don't use this sum at
all I don't have to so let me show you
an example where a user but here right
in this case you don't need this up you
if you want it to count the number of
triangles you could just sum dis over x0
x1 x2 and that will give you the number
of triangles
alright so let's do a matrix vector
multiplication I'm assuming everyone
here knows so the way to think about the
hypergraph is here you have just two
variables x is calling them x and y the
matrix corresponds to the edge XY and
the vector corresponds to the self you
be yeah now if you represent is faq it's
basically the form we have seen so Phi
of X you sum over Y with basically
indexes all of these guys fire of x 5 x
5 you so in this case I am actually
using both sum and product it is known
that in general you can't do this better
than N squared so there is no lower
bound and I come to this in a bit okay
so but we know we can do matrix vector
multiplication faster for more
structured matrices in particular this
thing is a number no this is a function
so for every X in the domain you get
this value so that basically corresponds
to the exit value in the output yeah so
yeah so I always talking about functions
another question
right so let's look at the discrete
Fourier transform okay before I go how
many of you seen the non recursive
version of fft before okay so for those
who are of not it was just as new I just
didn't know about this few months back
so I'll show I'll show it to you and in
fact our general algorithm specialized
to the DFT results in this up ok so here
so also remember the discrete Fourier
transform you look at the X comma Y and
pleased to think of X and voice numbers
between 0 and n minus 1 z raised to the
2 pi a time x times y divided by
government and i just want to show you
the intuition behind the fft so let's
assume n is some prime power raised to
the three so this won't give you the
ultimate n log n algorithm but we do
something quadratic and raised to the
four thirds only there's the easy
generalization to get unlocking out of
this ok so we have this what we are
going to do is then express x and y in
base p so x0 x1 x2 are all numbers
between 0 and p minus 1 and similarly
for y all right good so now let's
multiply x with y you just some
everything out and you get this sum over
J plus K between 0 and four you have x 0
x YK x p raise to the jeep is ok now
we'll substitute this sum over here so
you have some in the exponent so you
take it out you get a product just so
again the product is j + k between 0 and
4 and you have x JY k and p raise to the
j plus k now the thing to notice if J
plus K is at least three this value is
an integer so an e raised to the 2 pi I
times an integer so it's always going to
be one so you can just drop them off
from the product so that's same as
saying you only need to look at this
product when J plus K is up at most 2
and this factor of 2 savings from four
to two will basically make the runtime
go down from trivial p to the six to the
p to the four and i will show later on
but that's essentially
alright so so let me not just quickly go
through essentially the motions to show
why you can express this again as an
instance of the baby faq so we can
represent this J plus K between 0 and 2
as a correctly as a bipartite graph so
you have x0 to x1 over here y 0 to y 1 y
2 over here so x0 to x2 over here and
they have an edge between J&K of j+ case
between 0 & 2 then particularly don't
have an edge over here and then you also
put in a hyper edge between all the y 0
to y 1 and here's how you do it so Phi B
of Y just get replaced by this phi b y0
y1 y2 that's why you had this great guy
and this ax why is this product so just
replace this guy over here where psy JK
is is this exponential this sort of
express we express the DFT transform as
an instance of this baby faq instance
any questions so far
alright so now we want to talk about
algorithms for the baby faq instance of
what I'm going to instigate an algorithm
for this entire general baby faq I'm
going to talk about algorithms for the
two special cases joints case and the
matrix vector multiplication this guy is
mama Dell caused me up at home the word
algorithm is linked all right so before
I even we go talk about algorithms we
have to figure out how the functions
that represent because the algorithm
needs to not say the input
representation as well as the output
representation the simplest thing to
sort of it would be touring the truth
table representation so you just
basically list all possible input
toppers to a function and just store its
value next to it and just for the next
we sides for simplicity I am going to
assume the domains of each variable is
exactly the same its capital D all right
so here's a very trivial algorithm that
you can solve the baby faq problem in
fact you can't solve the more general
version to this essentially bloop for go
through all possible d to the capital
and instantiation of x0 up to x and
minus 1 then substitute the values here
compute this value and do this product
compute this for all x0 to xn minus 1
and then do the summation so you just
basically brute force everything and can
do it in MN times T to the N that make
sense
so let's see what happens for matrix
vector multiplication d is capital n and
little N and M are too so in this case
you get the tree will order N squared
algorithm but this is optimal for the
general matrix vector multiplication so
this trivial algorithm is optimal for
the general matrix vector multiplication
of course since I'm calling a trivial
it's not going to be optimal for all
problems so if we try to run this on the
discrete Fourier transform DSP and NMR
six so you get P to the six which is
again the N squared and of course we
want to do something better actually got
to do something that's faster than the
trivial algorithm and those of you
already seen the message passing version
of F of T this is what I'm going to talk
about next now I'm going to state it in
a slightly different way ok so again
remember this is diversion the effective
version of the DFT problem that we want
to solve this is the corresponding hyper
graph and so what I'm going to do is
start considering the Y variables one at
a time so let's say before I do that I
just rewritten the product and this form
our drop the exponents of our example
size 0 to SMS I 20 SI 20 SMS I 20 here
and ciebie is I be you so let's look at
say the at the variable Y to it only
participates in these two products these
two factors so what that essentially
means is all of the factors that are
over here are independent of Y 2 so I
can push this amin so this is an
equivalent formulation and now the idea
is i compute this partial sum first so
it's some / y to size 0 to x ciebie so
the idea is I'm going to use the trivial
algorithm here again so I just look at
all x 0 so the all the variables that
participate in this sum product is x0 y0
y1 y2 there are P to the four choices I
just go over all of them and do the
triple
with them again and i can compute this
sum of product in time order p to the 4
and the idea is once i have done that i
can store this output in a truth table
again and just put plug it back in so
that's going to be a factor over x0 y0
and y1 because remember we are summing
over why cuz we're essentially dropping
y tu from the picture so we can
represent this as a 5 fee prime x 0 y y0
and y1 so now let's look at the next why
guy which is why one it participates in
these three factors and particularly the
first three factors are now independent
of urban so again push in the summation
of y1 and again I want to compute this
sum product again I'm going to use the
trivial algorithm the variables are X 0
X 1 y 0 y 1 again just for variables so
again I can do this in time p to the
four and i'm a again going to replace
this by another factor which will just
depend on x 0 x 1 and x 0 so this is
where i'm at the n this Phi double Prime
and X 0 X 1 x 0 and have this summation
of avoid you and note that once I do
this summation i am done i'll get my fee
x0 x1 x2
so you do so again in this case the all
the factors that remain you have to
multiply again is a trivial algorithm B
to the four you are done so overall it's
P to the four which is n to the four
thirds in this case and you can
generalize this fairly easily to this
general and case so you think of saying
as P to the M burpee some constant Prime
and then you just stepped up you'll have
em such stages each will take time
roughly n and then m n times m which M
would be like login in this case
questions not yet that's one of the
things we thought about they think with
star since algorithm though is it won't
work over semi rings because you need
subtraction so it is a very interesting
question of what you can do if you add
more power to your some earnings in yeah
by the way this version said this has
been on before the specific version that
I talked about was energy stasis hi so
as you can imagine the truth table
representation doesn't give you much for
too long so here's our the very natural
representations which is let's look at
this value sigh e of x 0 fee if this if
this value is 0 since 0 analytes
everything you basically don't have to
compute this product anymore so the
moment you get something which is 0 you
know the product is going to be 0 which
means you only need to list the nonzero
values of these factors and that's only
the interesting not those things so
that's how I will present the input and
that's how you want to represent the
output so we have already seen this a
lot of time so for example for graphs
the adjacency matrix representation is
the truth table representation of the
JCC less is the Lessing representation
and in fact there is a very big
practical consumer of the listing
presentation with databases essentially
everything is in the listing operation
so it it's useful so we want to talk
about algorithms for this version so now
let's go back to the joints problem and
assuming now that all the factors are
given to you in the listing
representation and the output also has
to be realistic and let's try to run the
previous algorithm that we were doing as
before so we will pick one variable
actually turns or doesn't matter which
one you picked up whether we could
assume the dis factors are now size n
which means they have all n capital and
non zero so let's take x2 it
participates in these two factors non
divorce case you cannot prove anything
better so here these three guys you
cannot prove anything better than n
square you stuck at n square and then
you could say well maybe this is not so
bad because maybe ultimately are to
spend n square time and so this is this
is unavoidable so the question is is
this time necessary and another way to
think about this question is to say one
way to argue that you will need n square
time is if you have to say that you have
at some point output and square
triangles so if the worst case output
size was n squared then this time would
perhaps be okay so the question is can
you bound the output size and one way to
think about this is a three-dimensional
thing so you have access corresponding
to the three variables and you have n
values corresponding to C are over here
n values corresponding to s and when its
corresponding to 2t and you're asking
how many three-dimensional points can
you pack so that their projections are
these three guys as it was proved in the
40 is that there are at most n to the
three-halves such guys it follows a
special case of the loomis with me in
equality I couldn't find a picture of
luminous so the question is can you come
up with an algorithmic version of the
loomis with inequality so it turns out
even if you generalize the
representations a bit and allow the the
factors to have different sizes not
necessarily all size n but let's say our
Sayegh races r SS size s and T estee
size t then the loomis vide bound
actually gives you square root of the
product so what I'm going to tell you
next is actually a proof of this bomb
but the proof with automatically
suggests an algorithm to solve it at the
same time up to constant factors so
here's how I'm going to think about my
factors I'm going to have a column so
it's going to be tripartite graph column
for each of the variables and for every
value every pair insider I just have an
edge between them similarly pair that's
in sy t i'm going to have an edge over
here and similarly for serious and let's
consider some fixed value see in the
domain of x 3 so I'm just trying to
prove the loomis 51 so I just want to
count the number of triangles that can
be there so I call that's it is red pill
blue pill algorithm so you want to count
the number of triangles that are here so
there are two choices the number of
triangles that see can participate and
is that most the number of crossing
edges on this side ok so the number of
triangle that C participates in cannot
be more than
are or you can also count the number of
v's that go out from see so if we the
degree of C on the s side is d s of C
and the degree of C on Teesside is DTF
see then the product is also an upper
bound on the number of triangles and so
obviously you can take the minimum of
the two and get a valid upper bound of
the number of triangles that involves
three so the point is you make this
choice for every little C in C and the
run time of the algorithm as well as an
upper bound of the number of triangles
is some oversee men of these two
quantities any questions so far
oh by the way this algorithm actually is
as old as me so you can go back and
figure out how old I am but so this this
essentially this algorithm four separate
a network of it I and Rudy so let me
analyze this algorithm so this is the
run time again epic constant factors
there are some things you have to do
like have the correct hashes and play
something together but they're all
fairly simple to do so we want to
analyze this guy so some of minimum of
two quantities now we observed that
minimum of two nonzero geysers at moes
the square root of the product so you
write it like this so you have the sum
then note that this quantity R is
independent of C bring it outside your
sum of products have to use
cauchy-schwarz there's nothing else you
can use so you apply cauchy-schwarz
bring the summation in the inside this
quadruped so now you have some oversee
of the degree of see in the s chi square
root of that so this sum is exactly the
size of us this sum is exactly the size
of tea so you get square root of R times
s times T so you both prove the bound as
well there again they run time of the
algorithm is within a constant factor 2
or something the for the case when our
SNT are different size it can actually
be under unbounded Lee far away from the
actual on so there is an LP base bound
which is known to be I've seen the proof
of this through surest one yes yeah so
you has to make like all bounds which
follow from sure yeah so our generator
though basically argue this for any
drunk quick so you call d for any sub
graph any fixed sub graph that you want
to list we can get the optimal all good
in the runtime and which is linear in
diverse or something yes or dispersion
but yeah it's always use just like howie
shwartz the holders for the general
hardly Biogen proof is hundred yeah oh
yeah the lines you know Kwazii
regularity you know
like counting four cycles this yeah so
the original provides not decided it
follows from order yeah cause you rent
all right so let me just speak I am all
new senator I'll be quick so the general
algorithm for the general faq
essentially combines the two algorithms
we have seen so you start out run the
quote unquote the trivial algorithm
which is again the simple generalization
of the algorithm we software FFT and
remember at each point we were computing
this subproblem instead of using the
trivial algorithm to compute the
subproblem use a suitable generalization
of the algorithm is sort of John and
that's that that's essentially the
algorithm and again this framework is
not new it at least in the work of
growing marks from 2006 it's been around
so in some sense the thing that I didn't
mention was the fft algorithm work
correctly because i showed you the
correct order of eliminating the
vertices if you use the wrong order you
won't get the n log n time so in some
sense the only engineering design the
algorithm would be to compute the code
encode the correct variable ordering so
that's essentially the only problem that
you need to solve the rest of it is kind
of criminal so I just want to point out
the algorithm is simple so we have
actually implemented this algorithm so
for example listing or counting these
sub graphs there are many engines for
example from Oracle from GraphLab which
i guess is now data land there's also
systems from logic datsun snap at
Stanford so person is a colleague's
implemented this and so this is chris
again and android ed student lead
authors and they basically be the
existing systems botanics at least some
of the systems we're beating by our
necks ok so if you want to read further
on this you want to talk about so the
result that I have to answer those
questions we have a ver skits optima
john algorithm for all hypergraphs
disappeared in parts 12 so one would
think that that would be the best be
able to read up and one would be wrong
so please do not lead the pods 12
version there's a 20-page prove we
reduced to two pages so this is a survey
that we wrote which has the better proof
we also were able to show that bunch of
John problems new some new algorithms
for joints are very strong connections
with resolution and these give beyond
worst-case analysis guarantees for
algorithms and again this is the paper
to look at these algorithms are gained
turn out to work really well in practice
so we again we can't beat all systems
but we can beat many systems again by
factors of 10x and stuff and if you
wanted to know more about the epic use
this is
that question about the the variable
ordering huh it's a hard it's a hard
computation problem so to compute for
example the correct three with bound
which is what you would need for the
table thing is np-hard we don't even
know constant factor approximation